fracasos legislativos para el gobierno
de Gustavo Petro por un lado el proyecto
de ley que buscaba modificar la
Constitución para permitir el uso
recreativo del Cannabis no logró la
votación necesaria en el senado por lo
que se mantiene su uso solo con fines
medicinales bajo la eterna Promesa de la
lucha contra las drogas
Es legal en el consumo que es legal en
el porte y que es legal en la siembra
sigue siendo ilegal para la venta lo que
únicamente beneficia a las mafias y a la
ilegalidad hoy con esta decisión
definitivamente gana la ilegalidad
del otro lado en la cámara de
representantes hundió una reforma que
pretendía cambiar la legislación laboral
colombiana no alcanzó el quórum para su
primer debate y fue archivada la reforma
era liderada por la ministra de trabajo
quien fue criticada por no estar
presente en el debate el presidente
Pedro condenó la negativa del proyecto
el hundimiento de la reforma laboral es
muy grave demuestra que la voluntad de
paz y de pacto social no existe en el
poder económico creen que las ganancias
salen de la esclavitud las largas
jornadas y la completa inestabilidad
laboral el gobierno del cambio no
abandonará los intereses de la
trabajadora y el trabajador
el partido de gobierno aún tiene la
reforma pensional y la polémica de la
salud las cuales pasaron sus primeros
debates y serán discutidas luego del 20
de Julio cuando empiece el nuevo periodo
legislativo en Colombia
con una desaprobación del 60% para Petro
quien medirá su gestión en las
elecciones regionales de agosto